في مارس أه في حدود 120 ميلاً من
باغوسيان موسكو ثم توقف فجأة واستدار بعد
ظهر أمس ما حدث
لماذا
أه دونا ليس لدينا
معلومات كاملة بشكل واضح ومن السابق لأوانه
تحديد إلى أين سيذهب هذا بالضبط
وأظن أنه أه هذا هو
صورة متحركة ولم نر
الفعل الأخير حتى الآن ، لكن يمكننا أن نقول هذا أولاً
وقبل كل شيء ، ما رأيناه هو أمر غير عادي
وأعتقد أنك رأيت تصدعات تظهر
لم تكن موجودة من قبل أولاً في
رفع باغوسي في المقدمة  ووسط
التساؤل عن أسس
العدوان الروسي على أوكرانيا
لتبدأ بأه الحجة القائلة بأن
أوكرانيا أو الناتو بطريقة ما تشكل تهديدًا
لروسيا وتحدًا مباشرًا لبوتين
نفسه
لذا فكر في الأمر بهذه الطريقة
قبل 16 شهرًا
كانت القوات الروسية تعمل  على عتبة
كييف أوكرانيا ظنوا أنهم
سيأخذون المدينة في غضون أيام
محو الدولة من الخريطة الآن
كان عليهم التركيز على الدفاع عن
العاصمة الروسية موسكو ضد المرتزقة من
صنع بوتين ، وهذا يثير الكثير
من أه أسئلة عميقة  أعتقد أنه سيتم
الرد عليها في الأيام والأسابيع
المقبلة